الله يا الله لم تفتري الاحزان بعد وما
زالت تعتصر القلوب وجع
احوال الرعب التي عاشوها لم تمنحهم فرصه
دفن موتاهم كما اعتادوا فلجاوا الى دفنهم
في قبور جماعيه والهزات الارتداديه تتكرر
كانت ليله شديده البروده وكان الكل هائما
على وجهه لا يقوى على شيء اخرجنا الضحايا
من تحت الانقاض وبعضهم اخرج اشلاء اجتهد
البعض حينها وخاف من تكرار الامر او ترك
الضحايا دون دفن اللائق فادفنا عده اشخاص
في قبر واحد
لم يمهل الزلزال فرق الانقاذ كثيرا من
الوقت لذا سارعت الى حفر قبور جماعيه تم
ترميز من عرفت هوياتهم وكانت جثث مجهول
الهويه تودع في ثلاجه حفظ الموتى ليوم
واحد ومن لم يتعرف عليه احد دفن في مكان
خاص
في هذه الماساه قصص عن اسر كامله خطفها
الموت
مصطفى فقد ما يزيد عن 30 شخصا من افراد
اسرته استمرت عمليات انتشار جثثهم لاكثر
من اسبوع ودفن عدد منهم في قبر جماعي
ارفعهم باللحظه الاولى ابن احفاد
خالصين وكانتوا اول الجثث اللي طلعت كانت
ابن عمنا وزوجته
خفت كله بصيص امل في العثور على ناجين وان
كانت السلطات لم تختم عمليات البحث
والانقاذ بعد في هاتاي
الامل الوحيد هو اخراج ما تبقى من جثث حتى
تلقى عليها نظره وداع اخيره وتحظى بمراسم
دفن لائقه لم يتمكن الذين فقدوا احبائهم
في هذه الكارثه من استيعاب ما جرى حتى
اليوم ورغم شعورهم بالاسى لكنهم يجدون
سلوى في قدرتهم على مباراه موتاهم الثرى
في حينما يزال اخرون ينتظرون انتشار جثث
من فقدوهم من تحت الانقاض عمر الحاجه
الجزيره من ولايه عطاي